bonsoir pression intermédiaire merci
d'être avec nous alors la situation qui
n'est plus tenable pour le système
hospitalier notamment en ile de france
la seule solution le confinement selon
vous confinement le week-end parce que
je pense que la france est en état de
supporter un confinement on va dire on
en a tous marre mais qu'on filme en week
end oui on aurait dû le mettre en place
bien avant
oui mais alors là la question dispose
docteur c'est qu'est ce qu'on est
vraiment sûr que ce confinement le
week-end soit vraiment nécessaire
c'était le cas dans le pas de calais on
le sait est selon qu'ovide tracker il
n'y a pas de preuve de son efficacité
ça va pas encore plus entamé le moral
des français pour une efficacité qui est
dotée nous en tout cas environ danse à
rien alors je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous parce que mes
regarder les chiffres
regardez les chiffres que l'on a sur le
pas-de-calais sur la région de dunkerque
ça commence à monter ses fruits il était
à 8000 ans taux d'incidence ils sont
maintenant descendu à 6 ans c'est pas
mal le problème qu'ils ont si vous
voulez c'est que le territoire de des
hauts de france est tellement imbriqués
que c'est pas ça ne sert à rien on va
dire de contingenter ou de confiner un
département il aurait fallu qu'on finit
beaucoup plus large tout de suite là
vous êtes efficace alors on a quand même
106 jours de couvre-feu dans l'épatant
si j'ose dire confinement partiel donc
on n'en parle même plus est ce que ça a
été un petit peu efficace parce que là
c'est un petit peu déprimant pour les
français non après le premier
confinement street on est à la veille
des annonces en tout cas pour pour l'île
de france a conservé 1 23 million de
français potentiellement re confie
nabeul c'est très dur à accepter ça veut
dire que pour le moment le convive
officiellement n'a pas porté ses fruits
qui mais le problème c'est les français
cette année on a quasiment pas eu greek
peu de gastro entérite
parce que pour durer les gens sont lavés
les mains et ont mis à mars
or qu'est ce qu'on constate sur ses pas
une troisième vague c'est un plateau
depuis la deuxième vague actuellement
qu'on est en train de vivre
qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que au
début de la deuxième vague on avait une
contamination essentiellement par des
clusters dans les milieux étudiants
c'était la rentrée scolaire septembre
octobre
on avait les épaules parce que là ça
tombait comme à gravelotte et on n'avait
quasiment pas des contaminations
professionnelles
les gens en ont marre et commence à
baisser les bras mais c'est les bras
c'est à dire que il ya moins de
télétravail et surtout plus de réunions
avec des pauses déjeuner et on a
constaté la région que effectivement on
a de plus en plus de patients jeunes
moins de 50 ans est la cause principale
de contamination c'est la pause déjeuner
pourquoi parce que effectivement vous
enlevez le mas vous mangez vous discutez
bien tel besoin de contact social qu'on
baisse la garde et ça repart il faut
confirmer
uniquement le week end et j'ai sauté
parce que les français en ont marre
d'enfin vous allez les faire travailler
on voyait des enfants à l'école donc ils
vont déjeuner ensemble tout comme les
salariés et ils n'auront pas de
ressortir le week end ça va rien est-ce
que ça va porter ses fruits vous le
dites vous-même et lieux contaminés sont
ils sont quand on déjeune ensemble ce
genre de choses mais parce qu'on ne
respecte pas la distanciation sociale ce
qui vous est strict sur la distanciation
si vous êtes à plus de 2 ou 3 mètres
y'a pas de problème le problème c'est
que les gens ne respectent pas moi j'ai
vu sur les berges du rhône si vous
voulez ce week-end il y avait des gens
qui étaient avec des tables et de 10 je
ne comprends pas qu'on ne met pas on va
dire en avant la force publique pour
expliquer à ces gens que là
effectivement il déconne parce qu'ils
font ils font pas ils font courir des
risques et la deuxième chose qu'il faut
comprendre pour les antilles me regarde
c'est qu'on a changé on va le dire de
type d'épidémie jusqu'à présent on avait
une certaine visibilité terrible mais on
avait on va dire des gens qui se
dégradent est passé par la médecine de
ville
ensuite été hospitalisés et au bout de
cinq ou six jours on sait qu'un certain
pourcentage dans d'entre eux
vont partir en réanimation on n'est plus
du tout dans ce cadre là maintenant on
est si vous voulez dans des gens qui
sont jeunes qui se dégrade à domicile
que le samu récupère et emmène et
constatent à l'arrivée on ne peut même
plus à l'heure de spéculations ils vont
directement en réa donc vous n'avez plus
ce tampon ce matelas amortisseurs que
représente l hospitalisation ce qui
explique la tension extrême
on va dire dans les services de
réanimation parce que c'est lié au fait
que maintenant on est à plus de 70% de
varier anglais dans certaines zones
alors sachant que le valais anglais le
moins agressive des proies sépare
assurances comme audit alors parlons de
vue des transferts de patients pratiqué
en ile-de-france en ce moment ça devient
compliqué c'est une situation très
coûteuse
il se trouve alors d'une information du
jour que finalement beaucoup de passion
refuse tout simplement d'être transféré
c'est une mauvaise solution fait un
mauvais choix de proposer à non c'est un
très bon choix
c'est la seule chose qui permet si vous
voulez de garder à peu près 10% de
disponibilité si vous voulez sur les
lits de réanimation
parce que vous devez jouer entre les
différents services de régulation qu'ils
soient publics ou libéraux de manière à
pouvoir accueillir
maintenant vous n'avez pas de
prévisionnel sur la réanimation jusqu'à
présent que je vous ai dit on savait le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées en
caux vite donc on pouvait en déduire un
pourcentage
maintenant c'est plus qu'un dernière
question sur la sphère astrazeneca on
attend demain des nouvelles de l'agencé
européenne du médicament vous souhaitez
on imagine ardemment le retour de ce
vaccin pour autant ça va être compliqué
de restaurer la confiance
ça va être très compliqué de restaurer
la confiance mais c'est toujours une
question de bénéfice risque si vous avez
on va dire quelques cas de coagulation
intravasculaire disséminés pour va dire
quelques personnes en parallèle si vous
ne vacciner pas vous allez perdre entre
280 et 300 dix patients par jour
est ce que l'on doit sauver ces gens là
ça chante maintenant c'est des sujets
plus jeunes
versus une ou deux coagulation dont pour
l'instant sur le territoire français
même si le système de récupération des
données est une vraie passoire
merci la cnam quelque part si vous
voulez on n'a pas de preuve réelle
sérieuse documenté d'un lien étroit
entre l'astra et des cas et là les
problèmes de coagulation
par contre on sait que tous les jours il
ya 300 français qui meurt donc on
vaccine et on doit en vacciner
merci beaucoup pierre-jean terme honneur
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur ft
france